[Music]
hello hello hello how you doing how you
live and how you feeling it is the lef
koe man and we are back in the building
and back on the map and for all the
loyal fans of the left ghost show today
is going to be a treat it feels a little
bit like the State of the Union we have
a lot of things to clear up we have a
lot of announcements coming to the
future and I need to introduce you to
somebody and it's time to introduce you
to mr. David Inga hello there he is we
put in our arms away yeah I don't know
so David was hired recently what is your
official title now senior producer of
all things Adam left go I want that in a
business card actually I don't
yeah I'm excited because he's you've
been now here for two three weeks yeah
but right and everything in terms of the
show the podcast you've been helping me
kind of figure this out and we have big
things planned for the future we do
we've got we got a London trip we've got
we've got all sorts of amazing guests
coming up we've got some great shoots
come we're gonna be flying around the
country crisscross in the country from
meeting up with NFL players I'm excited
about all of it so first and foremost
I'm gonna call I'm trying to call you
Ingmar I'm trying not to call you Dave
because there's 40,000 David's at any
place that you work yeah any place that
I've ever worked there's at least a
third of the people that work like this
is a left last name podcast
it was Sims it was friend Rick it's left
go your anger I'll call you Adam though
just to mess with the system [ __ ] the
system we reckon it up just for
everyone's like brains umber is not
going to be the co-host of the show we
are in the process of talking to some
people and that would be something that
we've really been enjoying it during
this offseason making it interview based
getting to know certain players and and
not having to just do the NFL system but
when games start we are gonna need
another player to help break down I know
my own weaknesses and so we're in talks
with some people which is good can we
get real first like what are those
weaknesses I think the people want to
know
um I I don't I think that I get a little
hot-headed after a Sunday care too much
and that I don't know football as well
I'm a good question asker I'm not always
the answer guy and then with the betting
show we're gonna really try and get in
someone that that's their space and so
you guys have been have have really been
in the DMS and sharing with me how
important it is that during the season
we have those aspects and we are going
to have those aspects in Burres gonna be
the one that takes all the content to
the next level so as we're communicating
with athletes about the YouTube show
that's gonna be back this year he's
gonna be helping with those shoots and
coming with the ideas and you have a lot
of history in this in the past what was
your path to getting to all things left
go men I think the end of the journey
I don't know warrants everywhere you've
been but yeah the step one of a hundred
on my way to left go I got hired in 2012
to work for what was called the MLB Fan
Cave that was Major League Baseball had
this cool space downtown it was the old
Tower Records they had 12 superfans in
there every year that were watching
every single baseball game and they had
these players come by and I was on a
team of about three or four people that
would just write and create these
sketches starring MLB players a lot of
them are still online I ended up through
that job finding out that I could write
for Nick Sports Nickelodeon has sort of
a sports block he I was writing some
stuff for Gronk in times did you pitch
get like what was it guest line on slime
a lot of slime bits yeah that's that's
the way you save any any good bit yeah
exactly like in the same way you can
just say the aristocrats to save a
failing joke you could just say like you
know what and then they all get slimed I
was writing for Knicks sports a little
bit I worked for Cosmo the women's
magazine but I was trying to write some
sports as much as possible for them I
was kind of like the dude columnist do
you have a cover that did really really
well yeah I invented sort of as a it was
an April Fool's prank it just happened
to be in a February edition but it was
called Bros Napolitan it was like this
bro version of Cosmo that was kind of a
prank but then as we made it we were
like is this a good idea is this should
we just make this so I worked at Cosmo
for a while and then I ended up working
at a place called the kicker calm which
was a website started by Saturday Anna
as head writer Brian Tucker he's a big
sports fan we're doing like sports and
comedy kind of saw ourselves a little
bit like the onion and bleacher report
but like kind of halfway between those
two you know lovers of sports making
funny things sure from there I ended up
at the NFL Network producing a weekly
half-hour show starring Kyle branch you
know from good morning football we're
gonna have to get him on the pod let's
get him on the pod yeah I mean Oh two
guys you you two in a conversation would
be great you obsessed with like 90s NFL
I think yeah you'd be talking about
Barry Sanders highlights the other we're
gonna talk about the the guest requests
that you guys filled out but his name
was mentioned many oh good good
and then yeah that that show ended and I
ended up here I'd been talking to some
of the producers here at bleacher report
about working on a couple other things
it didn't quite work out and then this
thing was just right in the pocket and I
think I think it's it's it's a good text
a lot to you and me yeah sure a lot of
slack a lot of a lot of texting about
email there's a lot of ways to get in
touch with each other man but it's been
a lot of fun and so I wanted to formally
introducing Burt to the homies what is
your social oh I got off social it was a
really really depressing so I'm your
twitter IG completely I'm aware of
everything that happens on those
platforms yeah but no I am NOT
personally on there hold on you also
sound like I'm like an old grandpa or
something it's like that Twitter that's
not it I think no it needs to be on
Twitter I recognize the importance of it
I keep up with what's going ya know
you'll never find so that means when
someone answers your DMS guys it still
[ __ ] me so don't be surprised if it's
me
but you also created something that I
think is really cool that was a it
really started because of Bill Simmons
and Matthew berry I don't want you to
gloss over that sure yeah that actually
was my first first project it wasn't a
job because I very much lost money on
doing this it was now I can't I can't
legally call it a profession but I was
listening to Bill Simmons podcast way
back and I'm from Massachusetts that's a
big part of who I am as a sports he
wears a champions hat with Patriots like
that but but I respect the Patriots so
like it's not a it's just it was a bold
move but anyway so I've known Bill
Simmons since back in like the Boston
sports guy days and you know he had this
this early on podcast with Matthew berry
where they were talking about
gonna launch a fantasy league and you
can be in a league with Bill Simmons and
Matthew Barry what would you do to be in
this league and all these people were
writing in oh I'll lose 50 pounds oh
I'll do this I'll do yeah so I wrote in
being like okay I'm a musical theatre
background I'm gonna write fantasy
football the musical and actually it's
pronounced fantasy football the musical
it has a question mark in the title whoa
so I wrote that in and they talked about
it on the podcast which for like 23 year
old me was oh my god talking about me on
the Bill Simmons podcast this is yeah
and they ended up saying like you know
what we're not gonna take this guy
because this might be a disaster so then
I took that as a personal challenge I'm
like I'm gonna write this thing we're
gonna we're gonna stage it in New York
and make it not a disaster and as a
result I ended up kind of getting my
agent getting my first start in New York
as sort of a person at the Nexus of
sports and comedy so yeah thank you Bill
Simmons for rejecting me specifically
but you made it and it toured yeah we
made it it got published it got to be in
Minnesota in Philadelphia and obviously
New York and you created fantasy
football the musical and these people in
the musical and people in Philadelphia
like you weren't even there shout out to
the 11th hour theater company they're
amazing they staged it there yeah just
incredible people that got to work III
felt so blessed anytime I walked in a
room and there was like already a
lighting designer and already a costume
designer and I'm like wow these people
are here to make this show because of a
podcast all the others but Matthew berry
Bill Simmons and that's what I would say
to the homies too is part of the reason
why I'm so excited to work with Ingeborg
is he you you can tell like he reminds
me a lot of all of us where it's we just
love sports we love the notion of
community we love the notion of creating
things and that I loved that that you're
coming here with a different perspective
where the thing that we love on the left
coast show is to look at the NFL from a
different perspective and what I've
enjoyed working with Ingeborg with so
far is when we see an article the amount
of times that I've woken up to a text
from him of whoa big offseason and it's
a sarandon news article I'm like [ __ ]
yeah let's go I've definitely and
officially drunk the whoa big offseason
cool
addictive yeah once once I understood
the paradigm of what you were doing I
was now I see them everywhere because
all I do all day and when I'm not
specifically working on a specific task
I'm just reading weird NFL related
websites and you just find them and
they're just juicy they're so great
they're so good a little bit also you
mentioned London we have not been doing
as many live shows as stick to football
has but I know two that will be
happening in the next few months and
this is exciting because the left coast
show audience the homies we really
haven't done this so I have two dates
for you to circle we will be working
with stick to football September 16th
Monday Night Football Browns at Jets
Odell returns to New York Baker Mayfield
versus Sam Darnell I see Monday Night
Football in the lot getting pre gamed
we're gonna do a joint podcast the left
go show and stick to football I will be
getting a lit as I get off because for
me I don't get a lot of opportunities to
see you guys so it's in New York this is
great for all the New York City homies
in the parking lot well obviously have
more details but that is September 16th
which will be first few weeks of the NFL
season the other one I can't believe is
happening like there's part of me that
goes I'm waiting until they go just
kidding lol October 27th London we're
making it happen October 27th [ __ ]
London Rams vs. Bengals it will likely
be at some form of pub the details
haven't been ironed out yet stick to
football crossover left go show
crossover the be our football guys AKA
be our football we'll all be together so
to all of the international homies that
have slid into the DMS and said if you
ever come across the pond i will do
whatever it takes to get there
october 27th it's going down
yeah booked your tickets right now we're
gonna be there if you're in Croatia or
you're in for
answer right now like we're gonna be in
London that is a hop in a skip away hop
on the train do it but like let's let's
book get the Airbnb ease like I can't
believe it's happening but that will be
and and obviously well it won't be just
the one thing we're gonna try and do
stuff out there and create some more
content and all that but that will be
the live show well that's the game I
think is October 27th but we will have
more details about both but I know that
the international homies are gonna love
it
the best dude I I will say this man like
being off this past week and just kind
of interacting so much in the DMS the
the brand is strong right now and to
spend the last week and to see the
Austin Hooper episode gets so much love
like Austin Hooper texted me man and was
like bro your audience is [ __ ] awesome
because everybody was hitting him up and
saying it was great
travell Gaines is still hitting me up
being like the homies are still hitting
me up and all that I will say yeah
that's a real thing that if you're if
you're listening right now and you're
someone that's like it's only one tweet
what can I do seriously if enough people
feel like that yes say flood these
people's Instagram yes they flood their
Twitter's and they wake up the next
morning when the podcast comes out
they're like dude yes Adam left goes 33%
comes out like Kittel texted me because
I said on Twitter hey everybody one
skittle and he was like bro like
everybody's saying I got to come on the
shows like yes bro like you need to come
on the show so we're gonna get to the
guest request in a second quick eat like
a homey update challenge it is day 14 if
you're listening to this on Tuesday that
means it's day 15 and I will say that I
didn't eat like a homie all the days
hey that's part of eating like a homie
yes knowing with you can have a cheat
day and that's okay and being okay with
yourself and looking in the mirror being
like I ate like a homie for six out of
seven days yeah well whatever it is that
make you feel good I had guys being like
what do I do
I need late-night snacks and I was like
brush your teeth bro like like stop it
drink a lot of water yeah but I have my
anniversary on Saturday and we went to
this Laotian restaurant on Keo that if
you're in New York I highly recommend at
Khe - why oh and I
and my fiance looks at meeting us so
that's how homies eat huh I was like
stop guilting me but I did the math day
33 is June 22nd it was a Saturday so I'm
saying that I didn t like a homie so
that if you if you fell off we're
getting back on I had a salad again
today sit water
greens like a homie getting back to it I
will say buy a bike my goal for this
year was to get down 15 pounds and as of
last week I was down 12 and I think this
week I'm down 10 so I don't know what
happened but it over all right if you
look at the trend from January until now
I'm in the right direction and your
[ __ ] kick of that I'm making move you
don't look like someone that needs to
lose 15 well that is just sweet of you
to say yeah I need to lose 22 I did put
out on social official guest requests
where I put a few different kind of
topics you know who are some football
youtubers who are traditional media
members that you guys went on as the
guest cuz for two reasons one I want to
know who you guys want to hear from and
that I can give them to the official
Booker's here in New York and maybe they
can call up somebody but also let's use
the power of the 33% each week get I
think I'm evil figure out who are we
gonna target and then we can hit them
and say you need to get on the left go
show you need and not just tweets but
also DMS on IG and all that stuff so you
have the list yes
let's let's go who did the homies want
to hear from from recently retired NFL
players I was delighted that this was
the answer we have a guess who and the
number one response was recently retired
I'm gonna go Marshawn actually yeah he
was top five okay that Marshawn Lynch is
one of the most fascinating interviews
but but the homies came out and forced
from a man Gronk they won't grow they
want Grogg I mean that's a tough poll
you put a microphone in front of in
front of Grogg I I feel like he's gonna
say some fun stuff yes so we got Gronk
Chris Long Joe Thomas is a fascinating
Joe Thomas is definitely gonna though
you know Marshawn we got Randy Moss I
feel like would be interesting to talk
to it okay now people are looking for
Tony Romo in my mind though
Romo's in like multiple categories is he
a recently retired athlete or is he a
badass current media member who were the
other media members that we got I'm
where did Romo rank in that Romo was
number one so that's the thing Romo is
the number one media member that people
want the home he's like the number seven
or eight retired player so it's just a
different category I'm gonna star Romo
because he's now been on two lists right
um I'm trying to be resourceful with the
33 percent so I don't want you guys to
like half of you message Chris long and
the other half Tony Romo what other
media members Stephen a Oh Shaq and
Charles Barkley two of your faves
Steve so so we've already gotten Charles
Barkley there is a chance that we might
get Shaq I talked to Turner and there is
a chance in the next few weeks we may
get Shaq wishing me thinking of him in
that chair I was gonna say can I make a
recommendation as you just put some
phone books underneath yours and you we
organize the room in a sort of a fun
house type of way so that you look like
you're the exact same height yes and
then you'll just have that video footage
forever I would love Shaq anyone else in
the top five yeah we got Nate Burleson
friend of the podcast perfect we are
getting Nate Burleson this week great
just the fact that you guys wanted him
top five and that he was in the top five
I've already talked to Nate we are gonna
get him this week it's either gonna come
out this week or next week but I am
super excited for Nate but Stephen a man
I I want Stephen a the character and I
feel like interviewing Stephen a he
would not be that I feel like he'd be a
lot more reserved we interviewed him at
Super Bowl 50 and I pitched him on
second take it's just a more reasoned
debate show interesting like after he's
had a moment to come is a second take
it's we would do the show immediately
afterwards when all of water he didn't
like the idea okay all right so Romo is
the guy all right next one was favorite
football podcast that were not this one
well stick to football was the runaway
success and you've had them on so that
seems easy yeah
we literally sit next to some of those
guys and we just said we'll be doing
live shows in September and in London
and I would imagine we'll have them on
again who else
Pat McAfee the [ __ ] man I love Pat
is blowing up as a podcaster yeah we we
literally this was a behind the curtain
we literally texts each other positivity
all the time yeah like I'll just text
him I'll be like bro you're [ __ ]
kickin ass like he had the Jeopardy guy
on the other day and I was like great
[ __ ] get and yes like hell yeah laughs
go so anytime he's in New York I'm
having him come on
by the way can I just as a sidebar
obsessed with James Holzhauer and his
run on Jeopardy I've been watching every
single episode can I admit I have never
watched I haven't watched a second may I
suggest it it is it is what about it is
so great it's watching anything being
done at the highest level is amazing my
dad taught me this very early on just
when you're walking by a construction
site watch someone who's really good at
laying cement you know and just like the
perfection of the stories in the crowd
there there's something to James
Holzhauer is it's like God put him on
earth to be a perfect Jeopardy player
and to take the the calculated risk what
time is jeopardy on I check your local
listings I set my DVR for it and then I
just binge him on Saturday mornings
really that's a good move watch five in
a row it takes like an hour and a half
it's great alright I need to watch this
uh I see who else did we get on that
list you got big cat you like we got the
fantasy footballers robbers from the
ringer okay bill simmons obviously he's
always gonna get some love and a list
like this and I I had gotten a note from
someone that I think Mina Kimes was on a
lot and we're actually gonna have meet
on later this my heard that she has
agreed to come on so again if you have
any questions for Mina or if you want to
say congratulations
I hear you're coming on the podcast um
that way we kind of guilt her into I
don't want any of these people like step
it out yeah but I've never heard of the
fantasy footballers so I will look into
that and then Robert Mays all those guys
from the ringers you know if we can ever
get Bill Simmons that would be cool
especially now that I know your history
with him and just be like hey remember
that musical [ __ ]
actually and and one other job that I
kind of had along the way it was sort of
a weird little side gig there was a show
called Main Street without my mane yes
and Bill Simmons was a guest on that
episode and that was happening while
Fantasy Football the musical was
happening in New York for the first time
I was thinking like men it would be so
crazy if I was like writing on this
episode of Main Street and got to like
actually meet with him but I wasn't able
to make the trip to LA to meet him but
it's almost like we've been passing like
two ships in the night we were at the
same MLB all-star game at one point
didn't meet each other yes like at some
point I have to like you know and
friendly confront him and say like your
rejection of me is a reason why I'm here
right I [ __ ] love that I want that
moment to happen on the air like obi-wan
and Anakin by the way at the end of this
podcast we're gonna check in and our
favorite football player from this
year's NFL draft and I totally forgot to
say this we're gonna call Jonathan Abram
safety from the Raiders he is my
football son great freestyle rapper
great apparently cuz the Raiders I've
just seen on social they like freestyle
rap a lot but I just wanna it's like
kind of calling your kid at summer camp
and making sure he's having a good time
right I want to make sure Jonathan's
having a good time he said he's gonna
call us during lunch so that'll be good
alright another category what Twitter
follows did the homies like we got Aaron
Nagler normally we're a bleacher report
yeah so we I need to get Aaron on who
was the second one Ben Albright okay he
does some NFL there's a nice collection
of people on here a Dan Orlovsky you
know you know I don't think Dan's
allowed to come on the pod is that a
thing
ESPN makes it really hard bro hmm and
Dan such a nice guy that I think he
asked and I don't think so once you ask
then you write yeah the move is to just
do it and then when it when it comes out
and then blows up you go sorry yeah
exactly right who else was on the list
huh Brian balding er okay Ivan Silva Ian
Rapoport
so everything soups Evan Silva is I
think gonna come on later hmm when he's
in New York me and him we're talking the
fact that Evan Silva listens to this
show blows my [ __ ] mind and here's
why I look at Evan Silva as the
godfather of Internet football
discussion like with Rodo well I think
roto world is the most natural internet
football place like I felt like before
PFF kind of owned like we are the
football nerdy website I felt roto world
owned it and I have been reading Evan
Silva for ever an idea
then he was like dude I kind of dig the
show it's a little bit of like a Joe
Rogan feel and I was like [ __ ] hey
how do we get Elon Musk vaping on this
podcast we gotta make it happen at some
point right
yeah do you think yeah did people just
offer Elon Musk their blunts now like
they just walk up to him be like smoke
this he's like I wish I was known for
something other than this but yeah I
would love if we could do that the
middle of a podcast uh and then favorite
football youtubers comedians was just
like I kind of saw some of the responses
it's like Kevin Hart your favorite bill
burns great if knows knows it sports too
if we can get some of those guys on that
would definitely be your world in the
comedian world but who are the youtubers
favorite football youtubers we got some
great responses Brett Coleman okay
destroying I don't know if you know
these guys I do not I believe one of
them was a former UCF football player
they do these kind of really fun funky
football challenges like one was a a guy
he spins around a bunch of times
blindfolded and then they do Marco Polo
and he has to throw a football and try
to hit the receiver gotcha
a blindfold you know they do like
football yeah there's one where they
tried to out punt marquette king really
they just do fun football stuff I think
that's what I wanted to reach out to the
homies is because like these are guys
I've never heard of before you love DS
Brad Coleman I've heard of and he does
break downs and I think having him on
would be good and then there were two
more flim low raps and strong opinion
sports yeah I don't know those guys are
that's alright you know we're gonna get
to know them we're gonna look into them
we're trying to find the world of
football that's not just active players
right I want to know how does Brett
Coleman's set aside time how did he
build his community destroying like did
when did you go hey I don't want to play
in the NFL but I want to make crazy
YouTube videos guys like you know Evan
Silva
what was it like to go from nobody
respecting you to like serious NFL front
office's were reaching out there's just
these are the people that I want to
interview so thank you guys for filling
this out and taking the time hundreds of
you did and it helps us point the the
pot in a direction absolutely and keep
them coming keep the responses we're not
taking these responses no absolutely not
now we did make some predictions last
week for whoa big offseason whoa and I
think we did pretty well five had a six
if I recall five out of six so let's
check him out we said a young
quarterback would have a quote live arm
that happened to Dwayne Haskins sure
felt great we said that an NFL player
would go vegan Gerald McCoy a prominent
athlete this isn't like we were very
firm weren't digging into the depths of
some you know don't three school to find
a football player when I predicted it
where were you confident that this would
happen or you're like maybe we'll hit
one I thought it would happen this
offseason but I didn't know it would
happen during your specific week off and
by the way I will vouch for this I don't
know what camera to look at here but I
will vouch for this this all these
predictions were legitimately made a
week before and the following seven days
we have links to all the tweets and all
the articles these things actually
happen five out of the six that we that
we predicted we said that there this is
the one I was most nervous about that
there will be a fight at practice and
then the team would say it was good for
culture and the phone yeah the [ __ ]
Jets got into a fight and like Henry
Anderson's like it's really good for the
culture here it was almost like it was
almost like you had written the tweet it
was so on the nose so blazed like hey we
had a tussle but I think it's good for
the team uh we said that a
thirty-year-old would stay would say
he's in the best shape of his life I
mean the article about Jason Witten the
best like Jason Garrett just being like
I'll tell you what I've never seen him
in shape like this and I'm like get the
[ __ ] out of here that Jason Witten no I
bet you G sewins not really in the best
shape of his life right now but they
said it and that's all that we predict
all that mattered yeah we said the
return of Davis Webb this one feels like
a half because the tweet was so good
that it felt like he was back that the
tweet was Davis Webb just threw a
gorgeous bomb the Geoff Smith couldn't
have hand placed it any better
beat Chiron Brown I'm giving my I'm
gonna give it a half a point okay so
maybe it was a four and a half out of
six still a solid batting average the
only one we didn't get was wide receiver
gets into a fight on social media and so
if any of the homies actually saw a wide
receiver get into a dispute and we just
missed it please point us in the
direction absolutely but I think we did
well but
I hear that you have some lobokoff
seasons for me I do uh we're gonna do a
sort of a countdown of my five favorites
okay it's like I said I'm deep into this
now at this point you're addicted yeah I
am I am waist deep and waiting through
the the WBO is on the internet wanted to
start out with two of your favorites
Kliff Kingsbury yes and Andy Isabella
you mass product he's the next Victor
Cruz as far as I'm concerned
Andy Isabella is a white boy supreme he
is a burner the white guy that ran a
super fast forty and the analytics
community loves him so what is is this a
whoa or a whoa well I'll read the tweet
mocha side okay so Kliff Kingsbury was
impressed to hear the wide receiver Andy
Isabella spent Memorial Day weekend
working on his route running instead of
relaxing quote I figured it'd be at the
W or something with all that money from
the new contract whoa I love when guys
work during like Memorial can you
believe can you believe Adam left go
that there's a rookie in the NFL who's
spending a weekend getting better at
football can you believe it I love it
that reminds me of the Davis web story
where like he even worked out on
vacation what I those are my favorite
stories and I know that if you're a
Cardinals fan you're like made you hear
about Isabella
it sounds great it's a grind that's that
to me is a quintessential whoa big
offseason is the predicted response to
the will big offseason that a lot of the
fans are out there been like don't you
see you see that see Kliff Kingsbury
okay so you're one for one okay great
next up Buffalo Bills rookie Devon
Singletary I've heard a lot of positives
about this sure so much so that I saw
that the bills were even thinking about
letting go Allah Shah McCoy because this
kid's been doing so well he's making
moves out there and what's the whoa I
found this quote actually on our own
bleacher report.com highly rated website
highly recommend you check it out
this was the quote on one particular run
single Terry's decision-making on where
to run was so sound that offensive
coordinator Brian to bolshaya drum the
sidelines yeah baby great run this is a
great wall thank you so Brian day ball
the reason this is great as it reminds
me of the whoa big offseason we had last
year for Lamar Jackson
you remember homies that remember there
was a quote early on where Harbaugh said
there were times where Lamar would run
away and people would hoot and holler
from the sidelines
whoa this is a now I love when woes
happening back to back off seasons
because now it's one that I can predict
for next year it's now it's a motif now
it's a motif which is coaches yell
because of rookie performances I love
that so the fact that an offensive
coordinator brian de bal yet what did he
yell he yelled yeah baby great run mm
that's a super wall I totally like if
I'm on the sidelines as a reporter with
a notepad in my hand I'm writing that
down and I'm like yeah baby great run
scrabbling that's a that's another great
whoa it's it's it's things that
legitimately get us excited and then at
the same time we know would mean nothing
absolutely nothing but it gets you
excited it's also possible because it
might have been really sarcastic for all
we know we're just seeing it in print he
might have been like yeah baby great run
to the Gatorade jug on the side okay
number three
Russell Wilson wants to play until he's
45 years old oh that's interesting so
that's that's on the borderline of is
that a does that count towards his
offseason is that actually genuinely
interesting information not so whoa
nada whoa right mainly because he is a
kind of guy that I think could pull it
off and what we've seen with Brady and
LeBron and all these older athletes and
I feel like Russell like I look at Brady
and I feel like his devotion to diet and
any making himself more pliable mm-hmm I
felt like did not happen from year one
like in year 2000 Brady wasn't doing it
he adopted it late but I feel like
Russell Wilson has been doing this
really since day one and he's had
obviously the stories that make us think
he's a little bit crazy just with water
concussion water and all that but the
stories about Russell Wilson and the way
he trains and how he eats 45 just to
think about Russell Wilson playing for
15 more
years though because he's already played
seven right and he's made the playoffs
six times he's won a Super Bowl and to
think about he's had a career con amore
incredible and then to also think about
the fact that he just signed a hundred
and forty-four for you think about the
amount of money that he's gonna be able
to make over that time oh yeah kevin
garnett money just keep signing
contracts contracts contract well like
man let me see what else yeah I think
yeah I mean you think about like Drew
Brees and Tom Brady like wow I just I
never thought I just think of guys
having a 15-year career total not a
22-year career the question though is
will Russell Wilson have to become a
different quarterback when he's 35 36
because Brady doesn't take a lot of hits
though he doesn't he but but the the
shimmying the evasive nough straight up
he will reduce that overtime and so
it'll be interesting to watch him
transition from age 30 where I'm sure
he's still gonna be running around you
know 22 year old Justin but it'll be
interesting to watch him over the next
five to seven years and see how he
transitions into that more pocket
presence and them really picking his
spots and and running for first downs I
also wonder how it's gonna impact
contract negotiations mmm where you know
you're paying for his quote unquote
prime but if his prime is now gonna be
eight years instead of four years do you
now go to Russell and go listen man we
want to invest in you we believe that
you can play till you're 45 so we need
to figure out a Tom Brady like contract
system because if we're if they're gonna
keep giving him a hundred and forty
million over four years
the Seahawks had to completely rebuild
that defense does Russell then change
his monetary expectation to I don't know
it is he's gonna say I deserve it and by
the end of those four years to the next
contract might be four years two hundred
and twenty for all we know I mean like
that might be the new standard no cuz
the salary cap is coming it's just gonna
keep going it's not like football is
gonna stop making money next year
complete aside a lot of you have hit me
up in the dm's talking about the
collective bargaining agreement and why
aren't we talking about a possible
strike the homies know I have been
talking about a strike for the last
three years and that not only do I think
it's going to happen I am encouraging a
strike to happen do I want to go a
season without the NFL absolutely not no
one wants to miss football but as we've
said before
the number one way that you get more
money in this league is by holding out
it's the number one trump card so when I
see de maras Smith coming out and saying
that at the rookie premier that was in
LA that they're talking to these guys
about putting a lot of their their money
into like to everyone out there like
IRAs or like accounts that can amass
more money over time in preparation of
that and that they believe that a lot of
NFL players are ready to hold out for an
entire year I just want to say that the
2021 season or maybe the lack thereof I
am fully focused on that because I
believe that we saw it with Aaron Donald
we saw it with Khalil Mac I know that
Le'Veon Bell didn't get the huge
contract everybody wanted but he did
double up the guaranteed money that he
was offered originally from 17 in
Pittsburgh to 35 of the New York Jets
holding out while it sucks when it's
happening to your team is the right
thing for the players to do and this is
the players podcast and I'm just I
wanted to kind of talk about that I have
I'm all over it
and I know he wasn't on the guests
request list but I'd like to get to
Marius Smith in here one time too he'd
be fascinated to talk yeah I am
fascinated that he went from a guy that
got introduced during the last CBA and
now he's been there and he is guns
blazing he's ready to go he's ready he's
in defensive stance at all times oh and
I'm just I'm fascinated because I look
at the NBA and I look at Major League
Baseball and I see the security and I
look at NFL and I go how much could this
change like I look at what the NFL's
done recently we may allow our players
to smoke weed we may reduce the amount
of preseason games and these these are
the telltale signs of them floating
things to try and distract the Players
Union hey we might want an 18-game
season what they're doing is when you
get to the bargaining table we want you
to fight tooth and nail for 16 and not
focus on the fact that you're only
getting 47% of all revenue interesting
so I I look at
whenever I see Goodell putting out
stories about things that are not player
friendly whether it's replay or whether
it's opioids it is all to get the
players to not negotiate the money split
and it's that fifty two for fifty two
and a half forty seven and a half I
think that's what it is right now they
don't want that to be touched because
that's the money but they but they're
willing to negotiate marijuana and my
thing is is yes the marijuana thing is
ruined but do not take your eyes off the
prostate in the pocket of the argument
here yes don't don't be distracted by
the lights and that's why I want to talk
to de maras Smith all right so that was
my little rant about the CBA I enjoyed
it okay good we got two more woes okay
Russell I'll tell you if there Russell
Oh king of the Los Angeles chargers yes
he wants to be paid in Bitcoin star this
is what I found earlier in May Oh come
through down the gauntlet to NFL owners
and quote demanded to be paid in Bitcoin
despite this request falling on deaf
ears Oakland has turned to a hands-on
approach in supporting crypto repping
the Bitcoin logo on his locker
interesting this is a whoa I don't
understand Bitcoin like I don't I don't
either and I won't pretend to because I
say something wrong but all I do know
about it is that it's much more volatile
than the dollar that's all I've heard so
but what's interesting about it is that
like this for years 144 Russell Wilson
might be four years thirty million might
be four years 850 million right so by
being paid in Bitcoin what you're doing
is you're signing up for some volatility
and the amount of money you're making
could be a positive could be a negative
Russellville Kong's like bring it on
yeah let's let's let's just go with the
ebbs and flows you have any Bitcoin no
okay I have my money as stashed under a
pillow not my pillow you'll never find
it okay yeah cuz I remember like the
thing that I didn't okay
the thing I'm not processing is why
doesn't Russell oku just take his money
and then buy Bitcoin but I guess that's
I don't know it's not nearly as
interesting to say that yeah the one
thing I will say the reason this is a
woe to me and out of woe is one I've
never thought about the locker
as an opportunity for additional
advertising dollar oh sure
if you think about what players could do
is if they put brands now I don't know
if the Chargers will allow this but if
they put brands and then like on their
locker and as they're being interviewed
right behind them Utley displayed that's
very interesting to me this is like the
boxers who get tattoos of the name of
the casino on their back exist right and
then that their back is on television
for an entire right no 60 minute fight
so that's interesting too I think I
remember reading that Matt Barkley
wanted to get paid in Bitcoin to I think
what it does for Russell also is the
Bitcoin is one of those communities the
crypto community that they hear people
like me go I don't get it it doesn't
make sense and they're very small and
tight-knit and so for him to be the
athletic face of that as an early
adopter and I don't even know if
bitcoins early adopting anymore I feel
like it's when it had that boom a year
or two ago it was before that but to be
the athletic face of Bitcoin is a huge
opportunity for Russell oh cool and then
I also process the fact that he played
in Seattle in LA both West Coast markets
where with Silicon Valley and being kind
of adjacent do you think he was in a
coffee shop he was overhearing some some
smart guys with laptops - I've heard the
rumors of the Golden State Warriors
being involved in Bitcoin and Silicon
Valley so for me it's like I get excited
about the fact of players being ahead of
the curve so many times you hear about
athletes and their inability to be
financially stable that it's it's really
wanting me to get Russell okuma on here
and being like what am I not
understanding what do you know that I do
yeah yeah maybe this is his blaze pizza
this is his LeBron brazen please people
I think also Russell o Kuhn was like
really big into marijuana being
legalized - so Russell o Kuhn and
Russell o Kuhn also negotiated his
contract himself with the Chargers and
he got a lot of flack because he didn't
have a lot of guarantees in it and and
because he didn't want to pay the three
or 5% that they have to pay agents so
now I'm realizing I'm moving Russ a
little cuckoo very high up on the guys I
won't have on this pie
all right let's get them because that
there's not a lot of NFL athletes that
are willing to be that different and Wow
maybe we so for the show buying bitcoin
with Russell okay I'm just thinking like
if this was you know a Family Guy
episode we we'd cut to the future and
there would be like a cutaway and like
30% of these guys are all you know
living in their Bitcoin mansions and
flying around their Bitcoin helicopters
and laughing at all those like goofballs
down there that took American dollars
like a [ __ ] Schmo
I heard there's like Bitcoin ATMs and
Brooklyn like you can pay for like a
croissant with a Bitcoin in Brooklyn but
it's truly one of those things where I'm
so not like I don't watch enough
billions to understand crypto there was
a guy in some viral video I mean it's a
total scam jerk move that he was doing
but he was saying to people he was he
had these gold coins and he was telling
people they were bitcoins and he was
selling them to people on the street I
think he gave them their money back I'm
not sure how it went yeah it was a prank
or a scam or something but yeah if
you're out there bitcoin is not a point
it is a digital currency that you cannot
hold in your hand unless you print out
the code or something so the only thing
I realized that I don't like about the
segment we just did is I'm gonna have 50
DMS of people explaining to me crypto
don't be mad about that that's an
opportunity to learn about a really
interesting field I just want to learn
about football all right so so you had
five so one more one more just the
funniest headline on Pro Football Talk
literally the headline is Cam Newton has
begun throwing a football now now I get
it right he just got surgery I totally
get that people are crazy information
this the headline is just so woe to me
like did you know that Cam Newton
professional thrower of footballs has
begun throwing a football I am I am a
little bit still shell-shocked from the
Andrew Luck is because there was a
headline it was two years ago which is
Andrew Luck is throwing tennis balls and
that was a whoa that's that's pretty
well yeah so the woe of what objects are
people throwing he started throwing you
know medicine balls then he started
throwing rubber chickens because it's
like a spirograph I don't know
and that's how he learned it but I the
headline is very whoa but then there's
the notion of like it was really sad to
watch cam noon at the end of last year
there was one primetime game where all
he could do was throw the the underneath
routes to Christian McCaffrey and at one
point of the game they were trying to
drive and it was the monday night
football against the saints panthers
covered because Ted Ginn I believe
fumbled into the endzone on a two-point
conversion and that started that whole
like fumbling into the end zone debate
but it was sad because cam couldn't
throw the ball cam has gone vegan this
offseason whoa cam has had a lot of very
good charitable moments this offseason
but I am I'm naturally I'm like
genuinely concerned about cam so the
headline is whoa but with him I'm like
whoa yeah the actual content I am again
yeah I know that the actual content is
important and that Panthers fans and
fantasy football fans and just football
fans in general who loved cam who
doesn't love cam the guy's amazing
but a lot of people don't like it I
understand he's made some questionable
comments about female reporters and he
true he yes but I as a feel very upset
that he got paid in college yes people
also are very willing to say he's not a
good quarterback and I think they're
crazy but as a football player someone
that loves football what he brings to
the game is unmatched and incredible so
we all want him to be healthy playing
Cam Newton style football this fall the
other thing I'll say too is one of the
rules I love to have on the left go show
is if I interview NFL athletes and the
way they talk about a guy is glowing
then I will respect that guy every time
I mention Cam Newton to a defensive
player they just shaped their head and
go he's a [ __ ] animal like they're
always amazed at who he is and I went
back when Gerald McCoy got cut and I
watched our interview with him at the
Super Bowl two years ago and we were
talking about Kent it was right after
like Jameis Winston ate the W and he was
talking about how it was like the worst
thing he had ever seen because he was on
the Bucs
I remember that and I said what
quarterback to you really hate facing
and he said
Cam Newton he said there's something
about playing Cam Newton where you feel
helpless where on that big third down he
like runs over a secondary guy and he
gets up and like flips the ball forward
and he said Cam Newton is the best [ __ ]
talker he's ever faced oh he said and
I've heard this from a number of
athletes when you play can if he gets
rolling early you're [ __ ]
because he get he's a momentum
quarterback so if he starts feeling good
and he's talking [ __ ] like if you watch
a Panthers game and he's yapping in the
beginning of the game the Panthers are
the offense is gonna be clicking the
whole game but a lot of defenders really
believe if you can rattle Cam early he
gets into his head and so but we've
never seen a guy like Cam physically
play that position he's unbelievable
he's an incredible one-of-a-kind type of
quarterback but is he a good quarterback
at chugging beers that's here that's a
segue that's that's why you're a
professional broadcaster we used to joke
as soon as we get upset cuz I would call
myself the segue King uh-huh which is
you should never give yourself a
nickname but I believe that the biggest
whoa that we've seen thus far is
quarterbacks chugging beers it's a thing
now it is a thing it started off first
because of who did it this office it was
Aaron Rodgers was at the Bucs game
wasn't Aaron Rodgers was second okay
Aaron well there was a true Biscay video
at some point so give out shot give out
like the the props to the the chug King
David bakhtiari
David bakhtiari was doing it at Bucs
games yeah I think you're right and then
it went to Aaron Aaron Rodgers and then
Aaron Rodgers and it was kind of sad
picks it up and halfway through he puts
his finger in the air that was great I
thought that was really funny comedy
timing and I honestly believe that I
think Aaron Rodgers was joking yeah I
think he was doing a but I want to say
that I firmly believe that Aaron Rodgers
was doing a bit and that was not really
how he choked and it was a good bit
because he was showing Bakhtiari was so
proficient and he did the whole finger
up oh I can't do it
back if I believe that Aaron Rodgers can
chug a beer it was the equivalent of you
know like taking a sip of something and
putting your pinky in the air it was a
put-on yeah it was it was a funny you
know I've seen this from Aaron in the
past that he loves comedy he's a smirky
comedy guy yes honey yeah so maybe it's
because I believe that Aaron Rodgers the
greatest quarterback we've ever seen but
I am standing up for Aaron Rodgers but
then it's spread that night Matt
Stafford's wife post on an Instagram him
chugging it and then all the Lions fans
were like we have the best chugger and
the NFC North then we saw Patrick
mahomes do it in a st. Louis Blues game
which has come under conspiracy because
many people are believing that he held
it up to vertical for too long saying
that it was actually empty and that it
was not real this upset me a lot we're
gonna have to get some like real footage
a loss that's on this yeah then recently
Mitchell true Biscay add a game White
Sox
very impressive well done threw it down
service threw it down then at a softball
game
Josh Allen chugs out of a can not out of
a cup on his way to do the home run
batting tight so and there were two
things I noticed about the Josh Allen
one one can chugging is very different
than cuff chugging not as much like when
you look at Matt Stafford's there is a
opportunity for error to escape right
increasing the speed of Choo I'm just
saying those are different sports it's
like beach volleyball versus court
volleyball like I'm sure some of the
skills translate but not entirely sure
okay also Josh Allen gets extra points
though for doing it while doing
something else all these all walking all
these other guys were sitting in the
crowd and trucking a beer Josh Allen was
like in the midst of doing something
relatively important that's why he's a
dual threat quarterback yeah
truly multitasking multitasking so it's
it's really been a phenomenon that has
taken over
and so after Mahone not mahomes after
the stafford one came out last Friday
I'm sitting my apartment I had had a
drink and I was like I'm gonna rank all
32 quarterbacks in terms of their
ability my perceived ability of them to
chuck tweeted it out and it has spread
and I've gotten a lot of arguments
people have
very upset at me but I thought that I
would like you to come on and take a
look at my list yes I have it right here
what I did it's actually a very fun
exercise I just started off with oh and
also let me just say I texted a number
of quarterbacks in the NFL I did a lot
of background research race I texted
tight ends you're planning the work
you're playing the word I hit up Kindle
and I said I've never like what do I
need to know about Jimmy G and he gave
me some information so some of it comes
with background information some of it
was like completely guessing but I do
have the list and I put Kirk Cousins at
32 people can find the entire list on
your Twitter yeah all my Twitter
let me just give the top five in the
bottom five and then I'm curious what
you agreed with it didn't agreement just
so you know my agreements and
disagreements are based on literally
nothing so I did not text so I have my
top 5 from 5 to 1 as Baker Tom Brady Sam
darn 'old Matt Stafford Big Ben Big Ben
number one overall Big Ben is my number
one overall chugger I just I feel like
he's Bill Brasky
I feel like he might eat the beer can
like he just looks at a guy that would
look at you go
you even think you have a chance and a
chug off with me I could see that in
like in sort of a sawdust bar he has the
neck and the gut of somebody that would
have chugged a lot
he went to Miami of Ohio to Miami of
Ohio which is like known as like the
party school her effort stories Stafford
it was the combination of the Georgia
slash like video that I went oh he's top
two and there's something about Stafford
wearing the fitted hat backwards that
just it's an extra 5% to your speed and
chugging I have drank beers with darn
'old and I know that he loves beer and
there I also just wanted to give my guy
a little bit of credit so I threw him up
there the most flack that I got was Tom
Brady which I'm sure you're gonna pick
up in a second have some thoughts but I
have Baker at five there because I think
Baker just an Oklahoma bro that again
would go you think you could beat me in
a [ __ ] Chuck who moved to Cleveland
by the way which is perfect I I think in
Cleveland
there there's some opportunity to check
some beers my last 5 from 27 to 32
Russell Wilson does not seem like a guy
that would drink beer at all I feel like
that would throw off his whole diet also
I feel like like I saw him playing cable
thanos in Super Smash and I was like I
just don't think he'd be good at this
Lamar Jackson looks like a guy that I
just don't think just drinks a lot of
beer I just and I hit up some sources in
Louisville where I used to live and I
got some sources not the best beer
chugger Aaron Rodgers at 29 I
I couldn't move him I just I felt like
Mariota would be worse at chugging beer
he can check the tape on Rodgers like
you don't have to defend that yeah like
I had to put Rodgers there because if I
moved him higher people would say
there's video evidence but I still think
he was putting on Mariota if you've ever
seen the video of the Tennessee Titans
offensive line at a Predators game he's
sitting there waving a flag and he's the
only guy in the booth not drinking beer
hmm
I have a feeling that Mariota has never
had a beer the Seas below Rodgers who
didn't finish his beer so maybe he's
like a rose a chugging contest expert
I think Mariota is a this is Mariana I
really appreciate the offer but I have a
game in six months so I should probably
not he's just the nicest guy ever
I put Eli 31 because I'm an Eagles fan
and I wanted to say screw Eli I have a
feeling that Eli is probably more
towards the middle of the pack and then
I per Kurt cousins last strictly for
comedic effect and the other everybody
loved Kurt cousins at 32 I'm there there
were so many tweets Ingeborg that were
cousins at 32 gives this list validity
yeah I mean that's that's totally fair
because we all know Kirk Cousins is a
guy who wears Dockers with a polo shirt
and Birkenstocks and is on the grill
with you know it's kid all the kids from
the neighborhood are coming around and
he's sipping that IPA
he's sipping that IP enjoys it but what
do you he might know the most
information about the beer he's drinking
but I don't you think he's drinking it
I'll tell you about the hops he'll tell
you about the notes of butterscotch if
you ask Kurt cousins to chug a beer he
would give you a quote from a
philosopher about a time saver how
savor things instead of indulging
ourselves yeah
patience is a virtue left go and I'd
roll my [ __ ] eyes get that but you'd
respect the game I'd go your Kirk
Cousins that's the answer I exactly
right so what are your biggest qualms
with my list so number one you called it
Brady at number four and you know I'm
the world's biggest Tom Brady fan a
lifelong Patriots fan myself Brady at
four is insane right if you handed this
man a beer three different nutritionists
would tackle you he wouldn't even be
able to get the beer to his lips hold on
you've seen the The Colbert chuckin
right with him chugging a beer on
Colbert how do I not know this do I not
have the internet [ __ ] Google that
[ __ ] right now you are about to witness
a Patriots fan did it pop right up I
just searched Brady Colbert and you just
sergeant Shaw chug you are about to
witness a huge Patriots fan for the
first time see this video wow so I
thought you were gonna yell at me that
Brady should have been higher and here
you're telling me that you thought Brady
would have been 32 this I really feel
ashamed of myself just as as someone
who's worked on the internet for the
last decades I know I'm angry every
friend of mine actually are not sending
me this link all right
here's Tom Brazos in a sort of a black
turtleneck which you know awesome
yeah when Tom Brady does television he
looks like an evil villain he looks like
Archer
he's got the techies tactical turtleneck
nice he's holding the beer Stephen
Colbert is about to cheers with him
Stephen Colbert the blazer is off with
Colbert so you know rewind it see you
already missed it okay that's impressive
that's really impressive Brady Brand
look he even finished it was for Colbert
so after this list came out and everyone
got angry at me because I didn't move
Brady higher you had the tape no
apparently this is folklore with Tom
Brady I found an interview with who's
their current backup that used to be on
the Browns where Hoyer Brian Hoyer says
that it's the number one thing that it's
Tom Brady's number one parlor trick is
that he will compete with people in a
chug off and he's incredible at it and
and Hoyer even said this nugget which to
me is such a [ __ ] Brady nugget which
is he loves it because it makes him feel
like one of the guys which is what he's
always striving to do
right cuz Tom Brady really is like this
alien robot that like hey guys want to
go out with me it's Tom Brady but he has
developed this beer-chugging skill to
relate to his teammates so that [ __ ] I
[ __ ] love that's so Brady that he
would be like you know it'd be that you
know what would help me make some buds
on the team is to chug beers with them
and then he gets so good at it that no
one wants to chug with him yes they're
like dude we know you've got too far the
other way just swing just calibrate man
just calibrate it so I thought you were
gonna argue that Brady should have been
higher that's the number one complaint I
got on the list is that Brady should be
number one you know maybe this is like
the sports mother in me that just wants
Brady not to be chugging beers I want
him to play til he's 52 years old bear
also made him eat a strawberry in that
interview he'd never had a strawberry
before and Brady legitimately like made
a face as though he had eaten dog food
and I'm like strawberries he's like give
me a red pepper instead who else do you
think should be higher or lower so again
I've done no research on this but Jimmy
Garoppolo he strikes me as the handsome
quarterback in every high school
football movie where all his old linemen
are like running around with him and
they're the ones that are chugging and
he gets to just like hang in the
background with his letterman jacket on
so he strikes me as so handsome that he
never had to chug he could he could take
his time so I had him at 11 right behind
true Biscay and right ahead of fold so
11 that's just a pretty high rank that's
top third you know I I have heard from
teammates that the man can chug the
other thing is don't forget Jimmy
Garoppolo grew up in a family with like
five brothers in an Italian family in
Illinois and his dad as an electrician
all of the signs of a dude that got
[ __ ] down or someone that you know he
also went to Eastern Illinois so this is
not some kid that was like a big-time
prospect like I don't think they were
really paying that much attention also
you know who went to that school shuttle
Sean Payton Anton Robo but Sean Payton
noted partier so I had the feeling that
like I put all those things together but
I've heard that Jimmy Garoppolo gets
down and he can Chuck okay I will I will
go back this again this is unfair this
is like me debating sports with my wife
she doesn't really watch
bored so like any debate I can come out
here with facts and figures and stuff my
friend she's like I don't read ESPN
Carson Wentz
I have him at 20 yeah one behind Andy
Dalton who I misspelled and one ahead of
Matt Ryan and then the one that a lot of
Eagles fans got upset is I have Andrew
Luck at 18 and whence at 20 and they
thought that went should have been a
head of luck so I'm doing kind of like a
[ __ ] armchair analysis here but the
few people that I've met in my life from
North Dakota
shoutout to North Dakota unilaterally
and this is this is not me making any
sort of assumptions I'm just telling you
the three people I've met in my life
from North Dakota they tell me the only
thing you do when you're growing up in
North Dakota is find a field and figure
out ways to create a fun weird ways to
drink beer I know and you know when you
when you grow up in that world growing
tweet I got is he's from North Dakota
goes to Bismarck high school goes to
North Dakota State I mean this news had
time in North Dakota I just feel like
he's super religious and I'm not saying
that religious people don't drink beer
but like every time I hear Carson Wentz
talk I go I just I see him going there's
no need to chug your presence is enough
for me to feel uplifted so that I kind
of went in just I just didn't see Carson
as a chucker guy I'm just trying to
throw that's definitely one I could get
wrong I'm just just doing some thoughts
on it and then finally Lamar Jackson you
do think he could have just because he
strikes me as the sort of person like
when Ted Ginn was on the podcast a
couple weeks ago Ted yet you said
something about anyone want to race you
and his eyes lit up like no one can race
me I'm Ted Ginn right Lamar Jackson I
imagine he was that guy in like seventh
grade it was like I'll race you to the
foul line in the basketball court oh
I'll race you to this I can be faster
than this I can I can put I can shuffle
cars faster he's competitive yeah I just
feel like Lamar is that kind of guy and
that there was a thing in high school or
college that he observed that people
that there was social capital to be
found in chugging a beer faster and he
said I'm going to figure out a way to be
faster at that thing than anyone else I
just go that the Lamar from everything
we've heard is such a quiet introvert
and those are typically people in my
mind that I don't see
entering a chug off like I typically see
them falling back and like not being a
partisan this is that was more of a
personality ranking he didn't tell
anyone he was gonna be practicing the
craft of chugger ii until he was ready
and then he unveiled it at one place
also from miami and i don't know if
miami is a huge beer area growing up
that doesn't even make sense otherwise
but yeah that's how you can find beer in
pretty much any city in America yeah I
just grew up on it all right so that was
my list again check out Twitter and see
what you agreed with and what you didn't
agree with but I think this is something
that we can do going forward I don't
know if we're gonna call it the left go
list I don't know if we're gonna call
something but I love the notion of
taking quarterbacks and their
personality what does rank them and rank
them and and maybe we do coaches you
know maybe we do that eventually but I
think quarterbacks is kind of that
someplace to start so I asked you and I
genuinely don't know what are some other
possible lists we could do and what the
plan is homies I need your 33% is listen
a days list you can either pick one of
them or you can submit another one and
then for the episode that comes out on
Thursday I will release the other list
and then we'll put it on social like
Thursday and Friday and let's just do
this once a week we're just we're gonna
it doesn't have to be beer chugging
that's the flavor of the first well
that's the first one but we'll see what
else we can get these quarterbacks to do
and by the way I consulted with
hilarious Bleacher Report Writer
Dennis Flynn for these lead writer of
gridiron Heights
yeah so this guy he knows his
quarterbacks he knows his funny so you
know the we came up with some some
ranking ideas who would make the best
wingman that's a really good one it's an
interesting one right because think
about it
uh what I'll do is is as you pitch these
I'll do the Who Wants to Be a
Millionaire my initial thoughts first
thing I think of is a guy like Jimmy
Garoppolo you don't want anywhere I go I
go great to walk in the club bad to be a
wingman Connor Connor ruined that flow
for you and then I'm just like kind of
looking at the list then I look at Kirk
Cousins again though I go he's gonna be
the wallflower though that goes you
don't need to I'm fine we don't need to
go over so you need that middle ground
which you know is kind of a tenuous
ground to tread upon especially with
quarterbacks because so many of them are
alphas that they're famous as hell that
that also and I'm trying to have their
personalities like let's say if the
fames not there but more of their
personalities yep you know like like
golf would be a good wingman you know
what I mean like friendly jovial but
he's not like an outgoing kind of guy
hmm okay that's good all right what else
you got uh who would be the best at
making an Ikea desk that's amazing right
it's it's sort of a specific challenge
it requires patience requires patience
it requires you to like tune out other
things and just tell someone thing they
were saying that comes to mind Philip
Rivers because he's probably made the
[ __ ] nine kids you how many likes
Christmas Eves he spent with like
Swedish screws he he owns like he has
all the extra nuts and bolts that have
fallen off his other eye he could make
us separate the same time Big Ben ain't
doing [ __ ] right so that's that comes
into play these are all gets frustrated
halfway through and just like throws a
[ __ ] side okay that's a good one who
can do the most pushups just straight up
there's just an interesting one because
some of these guys are not all about
strength they're about agility and you
know a lot of - any any list where I get
to put Eli towards the bottom really
good this was a then I have to factor in
like Cam Newton shoulder injury you know
right that's all things these are all
it's good right this is one from Dennis
ability to get through a Pixar movie
without crying
Wow strong right you've really got to
think through like because I keep on
every like up oh that one get you one
Toy Story three ts3 dude I have never
seen Toy Story 3 get on it but I need to
watch it before I see Toy Story 4 or my
initial reaction who's not gonna cry a
Big Ben feels like a non crier like I
just keep going back to him what if he
tweets at you after this podcast but
holy just crying Flacco I feel like
would be a non-emotional stoic he'd stay
in the pocket yes okay I like that one
too I love the notion of quarterbacks
crying who cries at a Pixar movie that's
very funny
and then how fast they'd fall asleep at
a sleepover
strong that's unbelievable
I was the last to fall asleep at a
sleepover you always stayed up oh I was
the guy that was like playing twisted
metal that [ __ ] video game for way
too long so that's the question it's
like who falls asleep at 8:00 p.m. cuz
you know some of these cubies fall
asleep at like 8:00 p.m. like I'm at
4:30 to go for their first workout and
then some of these guys are like oh dude
you got a Playstation oh yeah like I
could see Cam Newton not going to sleep
at all I could see breeze breeze and
Kirk Cousins are like fighting to go to
sleep first and then like I want to joke
about like Kyler like Murray being a
baby still but I like all those all
right so homies that is the assignment
that I'm given to you guys right now you
can either use some of the ones that
Ingmar pitched or we are very open if
you have other ideas for how should we
drank starting NFL quarterbacks I also
want to ask you one question before I do
this I have on there Josh Rosen for
comedic effect is it better to have Ryan
Fitzpatrick because they're both Miami
Dolphins we're talking about just
including in these lists throughout the
year well this is the thing I'm wrote
down starting NFL quarterbacks cuz
otherwise like bortles is gonna be in
there and Ryan Fitzpatrick is gonna be
in there but I'm trying to keep it to 32
but is it better to have Josh Rosen or
is it better to have Fitzpatrick like I
don't I feel like Josh Rosen is gonna be
the starter that's why I put him down I
think I think if we're gonna do this
week to week right we can just look at
who's gonna be the starter that week and
that's the listeners taking first snaps
who's taking first snaps on the first
team in practice this week right so it's
your list I mean you could do the
official training camps start this week
so like Odell's finally gonna report to
Cleveland this week so we should get
will the the the tricky teams the Miami
team will kind of pay attention to who
is taking first team snaps and they will
be yet but homeys this is your
playground how are we ranking these
quarterbacks which of bers ideas did you
like which of ideas
do you like and we're gonna make this
the new left co-list or whatever the
[ __ ] we're gonna name hard so I had to
check out on my favorite rookie I gotta
see how camp is going for the big dog
Jonathan Abram where are you right now
what are we doing man you're ready for
me which means darn it two o'clock all
right so as soon as you need to go say
left call I got a roll deal yeah
all right so dude how's it been how's it
going man I'm pretty the team really
loves me you know coaches really love me
I think this is probably the best you
know looking back on you know the places
that I could have landed up I don't
think I want dude so got a really good
team running really good teams
surrounded by some little guys on both
sides of the ball man produce young guy
Abram you sound like a pro right now
these are really good Pro answers I'm
not gonna lie I texted two of your
teammates I'm not gonna tell you who
they are and they both said you're a dog
so just know the veterans are liking
what you're doing this far man can you
feel that
no yeah man just come on everyday just
trying to be myself making sure I'm on
top of my stuff you know so I'll give
them no reason say I'm making I'm
curious how have how have my homeys my
33% have my listeners been messaging you
a lot are they showing you the love oh
yeah oh yeah a little dance hey show me
love I read somewhere that you are happy
to be mentored by LaMarcus Joyner what
is that relation what is that
relationship right now kind of share
that with everybody man is like a weird
religious it was kind of like a big
brother
kind of like an uncle cuz he young buddy
oh it's like he's a weird guy but he's a
really great guy
no family oriented you know he doesn't
have any social media you know either
care for any a day you know you don't
care what nobody you know cuz it like
you told me they don't give me no chick
they don't put no money in my pocket so
they don't really care for it so you
know talking to him
kind of like talking to like I say like
uncle hmm you know you're always giving
me any giving me advice you know just
telling me you know ways to go about
things and and he's always constantly
reminding me you know why I'm here you
know my purpose you know just to be Who
I am
you told me before the draft that you
were so excited to be a pro because you
were ready to make it your full-time job
is there anything that you you didn't
like has it been easier has been harder
has it been like a lot of joy making
your full time job like what has it been
like the first few weeks first week was
probably my worst week I thought I was
signing in my family situation you know
it was pretty tough you know moving from
Mississippi all the way to Oakland so
like I said I wrote my first one I don't
tell my words we look like my roughest
week so you know it was just restful you
know just trying to get everything
apartment and family move your car and
everything in China you know because
they put a lot on me you know I've been
learning a lot of positions you know I
have to know it thoroughly you don't
have to know certain ticks because I
have to I have to be interchangeable cuz
we're gonna do a lot of math you know so
fish here so that was probably the worst
as week but after that man is I'm pretty
much smooth sailing no defense they all
look out for my summer go so how's it
going pretty good and then I see that
the locker room man we got some free
styles going on I'm just seeing this
with all the Raiders IG right now so are
they making all the rookies freestyle
how does this work yeah man they call it
uh Ricky rap battle Thursdays whoo so it
only happens on Thursdays mm-hmm I love
it and however you have you had to go
yet and how did you do you know they
made me started I was the first to go I
ripped it the first week I even got the
Ripper know some of this name so they
won't let me get back on the micro
security so then we had Kony and um and
Alec Ingold the full-back children I saw
yeah no doubt you turned my man max max
cause back yeah back door so max Crosby
he's one of your tight end mardian
OD end he went out there and was
freestyling crazy we who were the
veterans that you got they
you were like oh man maybe I shouldn't
have gotten them no okay no not be ready
to rap battle
dude you gotta let me come cuz I just
want I only want a rap battle and then
I'll leave do you think they would like
to do that yeah all right you come on
Thursday they go beyond for did we
really get mighty anybody oh they're
gonna tear me to shreds they gonna be
like was your dumbass sweater in this
howto ass whether I can't feel it
already what you killed if you kill it
on the route they go they go play that's
awesome are you still like I remember
you had that one post where you saw
Gruden working out how's everything
going Brewed and you guys still lifting
together and all that stuff oh yeah yeah
the workout looks pretty good you know
getting stronger getting faster so
that's all the workout program has been
probably the smoothest part you know
everything just we go in there we get
after it cuz you know a lot of people
realize how important that part of it is
cuz it all translates boss he'll tell
you that workout has been great mmm all
right I know you got to get to a meeting
so it was good to catch up I wanted to
make sure that everything was good you
got a message you got a message to
Raider Nation and left go nation out
there just win baby
that's awesome Abram you're the man dude
keep kicking ass my friend proud of you
all right all right
Jonathan Abram we're gonna keep checking
in I told you he's gonna be our favorite
rookie this year
and he's already out there and I'm
telling you I have heard from two guys
on that team that said he is a dog so
everything is going well I want to say
thank you to mr. Engler for being here I
hope you guys enjoyed him he is really
gonna help take this podcast to the next
level and also the show that will be
coming up later I hope you guys are
excited in September for the Browns Jets
game when we're doing a live show and
then also the one in London in October
October 27th all I need from you guys
right now though is what is the
quarterback list that we need to put out
next let me know the lef koe man holla
holla holla
at you guys later love you 33% y'all are
the [ __ ]